[Música]
nos próximos quinze minutos
só no brasil 510 mulheres serão abusadas
psicologicamente 1 153 mulheres serão
agredidas fisicamente e duas mulheres
serão mortas e os seus parceiros
o ex parceiros esse quadro geral e
alarmante dos impactos dos
relacionamentos abusivos no nosso país
reverbera em vários âmbitos 1 na nossa
economia por exemplo são mais de 14
milhões de dias de trabalho perdidos por
trimestre
o concurso social de mais de 3 bilhões
de reais
isso sem contar com gastos de
previdência social e cursos de saúde
a violência contra a mulher
ela é algo tão naturalizado de ampla que
se eu fechar meus olhos e chamar
qualquer mulher para vir aqui em cima
ela terá um caso de abuso para
compartilhar considero relacionamento
abusivo quando em um casal uma pessoa
causa danos ao corpo autonomia
individualidade dignidade e
desenvolvimento da outra pessoa
eu vou me referir aqui ao abusador como
ele ea vítima como ela porque esses
termos refletem corretamente o que
acontece na grande maioria dos casos de
relacionamentos abusivos com o cenário
de números tão assustadores porque nossa
sociedade ainda falamos
pensamos e agimos como se esse problema
fosse do casal de ordem individual e
última nós já sabemos há um bom tempo
que esse problema não é de ordem privada
mas continuamos lidando como se fosse eu
vou mostrar para vocês três formas como
nós sociedade fazemos isso nós lidamos
com os efeitos psicológicos que são
conseqüências do abuso como se fosse
algo diferente disso nós não intervimos
socialmente quando vemos o abuso e
repetimos de geração para geração uma
cultura que é solo fértil para criação
de potenciais personagem de
relacionamentos abusivos
eu estou falando da desigualdade de
gênero
então vamos ao primeiro ponto
eu observo que existem efeitos
psicológicos da vítima de
relacionamentos abusivos que são
raramente tratados
lidamos com eles como se fosse algo
problema da mulher não como se fosse
abuso em seu conseqüência do abuso
são cinco os principais efeitos
psicológicos
eu não observa abuso mesmo quando todos
ao meu redor percebem
eu me culpo excessivamente acredito que
eu fiz algo errado e que eu estou sendo
punida por isso
eu sinto esperança de que o abuso irá
acabar
mesmo sem nenhum sinal real de que está
acabando apenas piorando
eu não sinto medo mesmo em situações de
risco
e aqui é muito importante frisar que a
ausência de medo da vítima não pode ser
levado em consideração para análise de
perigo e o quinto e último efeito
psicológico é eu acredito que só
acontece comigo eu acho que só eu estou
passando por isso
me mantenho isolada sem rede de apoio
em apoio social com mais vergonha e mais
culpa não lhe darmos com os efeitos
psicológicos como eles são
gera principalmente abusos graves e
explícitos como esse que eu vou contar
pra vocês agora
em uma enquete na qual eu perguntava
quais as exigências você precisava
cumprir no seu relacionamento abusivo
uma participante que eu vou chamar aqui
de joana respondeu eu só posso tomar
banho com ele
se eu tomar banho sozinha ele acredita
que é porque eu tive relação sexual com
alguém
estou limpando além de gerarmos abusos
graves explícitos como esse não lhe
darmos com os efeitos psicológicos como
eles são
leva ao apagamento da sociedade como
parte de construção do fenômeno e isso
nos leva ao segundo ponto o que nós
sociedade temos feito quando vemos o
abuso
nós familiares e amigos quem assiste ao
abuso bom
no caso da minha paciente que é que eu
vou chamar de marina
quando ela estava dentro do carro como
seu namorado durante uma briga e ele
dirigir agressivamente
ela estava com ele e lhe dirigir
agressivamente ele jogou por querer o
carro no poste
quem assistiu à cena além de não dar
apoio não fez nada
isso resultou nela acreditar que ela
estava errada ninguém fez nada eu tô
errada eu só posso estar louca mesmo a
ausência de intervenção social só
beneficia o abusador
a ausência de intervenção social causa
reforça a idéia de que o problema
individual enquanto música alta no
vizinho me incomodar mais
do que os gritos de violência do andar
de baixo enquanto mantivermos o nosso
silêncio haver abusos
esses últimos dois exemplos que eu
trouxe pra vocês agora é da marina joana
são exemplos mais explícitos mais graves
e talvez mais fáceis da gente perceber
mas sabe quando ele implica com a cor do
seu esmalte ou com a sua roupa ou quando
ele utiliza de tratamento de gelo e até
mesmo elogios para conseguir o que ele
quer de você sabe quando ele fica
emburrado porque você não quer ter
relação sexual
e se você confronta os maus tratos
ele te responde que é isso você é muito
sensível
eu só estava brincando você tá louca ou
e até mesmo fala ninguém nunca vai te
amar como eu você nunca vai encontrar
alguém como eu pois bem todos esses
exemplos são exemplos de abusos utis
talvez mais difíceis a gente perceber
mais disfarçados de elogio de proteção
de carinho e cuidado mas são todos os
abusos
o que nos leva ao terceiro ponto que a
cultura que permite que esse abuso
aconteça e se multiplique a desigualdade
de gênero nessa cultura
a gente cria a idéia de que a mulher é
subalterno responsável por esse
casamento e até mesmo que ela é objeto
extensão desse parceiro a desigualdade
de gêneros silencia as mulheres e
infelizmente criamos homens
manipuladores controladores e
silenciadores de mulheres desde muito
novinhas
nós mulheres escutávamos se fulano bater
em você no colégio na escola é porque
ele gosta de você
nós vamos aprendendo que
o uso é amor enquanto compactuarmos com
a desigualdade de gênero
continuaremos produzindo entre outras
coisas a eliminação em massa de mulheres
então esse é o cenário são muitas e
muitas mulheres
algumas nem sabem que estão em um
relacionamento abusivo
algumas não têm recurso força para sair
todas estão ocupadas isoladas
ansiosas deprimidas confusas e o cenário
a cultura da desigualdade de gênero
então o que fazer quais são as
possibilidades saídas o que tem sido
feito bom terapia individual e em grupo
e em grupo políticas públicas e
investimento nas políticas públicas
aumento da igualdade de gênero criação
de condições de igualdade de trabalho e
independência econômica tem várias
coisas sendo feitas
eu vou destacar hoje um elemento que tem
sido pouco tratado nesse tema mas pode
ser incorporado ao debate como
possibilidade de saída para os
relacionamentos abusivos
a compaixão que pode ser definida como o
desejo de alívio do sofrimento do outro
o dalai lama definir compaixão como uma
abertura o sofrimento do outro com
comprometimento de live ao quando esse
outro somos nós mesmos
nomeamos de autocompaixão antes restrita
à religião
hoje ela tem sido estudada como conceito
acadêmico na ciência há uma década de
forma laica
nós já sabemos alguns dos benefícios da
compaixão como aumento da conexão social
diminuição de ansiedade aumento da saúde
diminuição de autocrítica vergonha de
pressão
há uma década eu atuo com psicóloga
clínica e uma parte substancial do meu
trabalho tem sido lidar com os
relacionamentos abusivos sofridos pelas
minhas pacientes
essa experiência resultou na fundação da
não era amor uma iniciativa para
informar e prestar atendimento
psicológico às mulheres que estão ou
saíram de relacionamentos abusivos a não
era amor surgiu para ensinar às pessoas
que abuso não éramos eu tive a
experiência de trazer a compaixão para
esse meu contexto do trabalho ea partir
do momento que eu trago ela para o
processo começa aconteceu o seguinte a
mulher consegue romper com o ciclo da
violência ela restaura sua saúde mental
e sua autoestima e ela se torna
novamente o centro de sua própria vida
ela aprende entende que abuso e
violência não são aceitáveis de uma
relação e mais bonito que isso elas se
tornam agentes multiplicadores da
compaixão é bem tocante de ver
precisamos de compaixão para essas
mulheres para que elas se sintam
ajudados acolhidas e principalmente
acreditadas precisamos de compaixão para
que elas consigam aumentar a sua auto
compaixão a não era amor ela surgiu para
ajudar as vítimas
mas nós estamos vendo que com paixão só
com as mulheres não resolve
completamente o problema
a pergunta que mais me fazem a campeão é
pole
você acha que ele vai mudar aqui de que
ele vai mudar e vai mudar
mais de 65% dos abusadores possui um
padrão e vai repetir isso com novas
vítimas
nós precisamos de muita sabedoria
para distinguir uma mudança real
profunda e sincera de uma promessa de
mudança abuso manipulação recompensa
após briga para que o abusador mude ele
precisa passar por alguns processos
muito importantes
ele precisa reconhecer que está errado
de forma humilde ele precisa parar de
justificar e minimizar o abuso e ele
precisa parar de culpabilizar a vítima
pelo que ele faz e novamente eu acredito
que nós só conseguiremos isso com
compaixão a compaixão nasce com a gente
todos nós nascemos com passivos mas nós
vamos perder nessa habilidade em 11 de
goes está centrado que alimenta a
indiferença é possível resgatar e
treinar a compaixão quando nós treinamos
o cérebro muda via um processo chamado
chamado neuroplasticidade compaixão é um
processo em construção
nós precisamos levar essa construção
para as rodas de amigos almoços de
família para os nossos trabalhos nossas
empresas para as nossas polícias para as
nossas políticas públicas e
principalmente para criação dos nossos
filhos
imaginem nossas crianças desde
pequenininhos até todo o seu
desenvolvimento sendo criadas em um
mundo baseado na compaixão teríamos
gerações e gerações de pessoas que não
mais multiplicam abuso mas agora
multiplicam amor vai ser quase
impossível a mulher sair do abuso sem
intervenção social vai ser impossível
pararmos mais abusos sem mudança social
e só vai ser possível se nos mantivermos
no processo da compaixão
ela começa
termina com a gente eu tenho um sonho
maior e eu acredito preciso da ajuda de
todos vocês
o cronômetro só vai parar com compaixão
muito obrigado
[Música]